aujourd'hui 60% des pannes d'appareils
électriques et électroniques ne sont pas
réparés alors pour y remédier depuis le
15 décembre dernier l'État met la main à
la poche pour encourager les Français à
prolonger la durée de vie de leurs
appareils et réduire les déchets 10 à 15
euros d'aide par réparation pour en
bénéficier il faut s'adresser aux 500
ateliers agréés comme Murphy l'un des
leaders du marché on en voit pas
beaucoup à céder comme ça tu as de la
valeur ça c'est demander en région
parisienne et tout des petits scènes on
a du mal à en sortir mais ça fait
plaisir quand on a Murphy répare 5000
appareils d'électroménager chaque mois
et réalise un chiffre d'affaires de plus
de 5 millions d'euros si le coût de la
réparation avec cette pas 40% du prix du
neuf en fait la plupart des
consommateurs préfèrent passer par la
réparation au niveau national on aura
réparé 100 000 appareils en 2022 100 000
soit 0,4% des 28 millions d'appareils
ménagers qui tombent en panne chaque
année face à la demande qui expl la main
d'oeuvre est insuffisante nous on a
formé on a embauché 150 réparateurs dans
les 18 derniers mois et là l'enjeu et
l'ambition c'est d'un reformer dans
embaucher 300 dans les 18 prochains mois
donc on est sur une enjeu assez assez
importante la France compte 5000
réparateurs sur tout le territoire alors
qu'il en faudrait le double pour faire
face à cette pénurie Murphy a pris à
bras le corps la situation en créant sa
propre école pour former les réparateurs
de demain ça peut être la carte
interface il faut bien regarder donc on
va les retrouver ou sur le schéma
pendant six mois les élèves alternent
entre théorie et pratiques on voit de
tout du lave-linge à la cuisson en
passant par le réfrigérateur et on
détaille tous les principes de
fonctionnement des appareils avant j'ai
été restaurateur pendant 14 ans moi ce
qu'il me fallait c'est un métier qui
soit utile en fait la restauration c'est
bien mais c'est pas c'est pas vital en
fait c'est quand on a pas d'argent on va
pas au resto quoi mais quand ta machine
elle tombe en panne bah tu es obligé de
la faire réparer Sébastien débutera sa
carrière à 1800 euros brut par mois et
pourra doubler rapidement ses revenus si
le marché continue de s'accroître mais
pour relever le défi de la réparabilité
la pénurie de main d'oeuvre n'est pas le
seul obstacle trouver les bonnes pièces
détachées peut aussi se révéler être un
vrai casse-tête nous sommes dans la
banlieue de Lyon chez Utopia spécialiste
des pièces détachées pour téléphone
portable ici 30000 composants sont
expédiés chaque jour avec comme promesse
une livraison partout en France en 24
heures en particulier toutes les cases
son téléphone il emmène à une boutique
de réparation cette boutique là n'a pas
forcément la pièce en stock elle va le
commander sur Utopia si on n'est pas
capable nous de livrer cette pièce
détachées en 24 heures il y a des
grandes chances que vous n'alliez pas ça
réparer votre téléphone et que vous
préfériez le changer Aldric a créé
Utopia en 2013 à l'époque il livre
lui-même à vélo les réparateurs des
environs depuis l'entreprise connaît une
forte croissance plus 30% en moyenne
chaque année aujourd'hui son chiffre
d'affaires frôle les 60 millions d'euros
ce qui est intéressant c'est que là tu
es sûr de pouvoir faire des commandes
quasiment sans aucune erreur alors pour
honorer toujours plus de commandes en un
temps record Aldric a dû investir
quelques millions d'euros dans un
entrepôt high-tech
numéro 20 la balle est pas mal
besoin de marcher dans les allées pour
trouver la bonne référence 25 robots
très organisés se baladent parmi le
million de pièces détachées et la porte
directement au magasinier
quand même finalement plus qu'on pensait
non selon Aldric la masse salariale
n'aurait pas vraiment diminué ce système
lui permettrait de limiter les erreurs
de commande de rendre la tâche plus
confortable pour le personnel
d'anticiper l'avenir et son nombre
croissant de commandes problème les
fabricants ne sont pas toujours très
collaboratifs et rechigne parfois à
fournir les bonnes pièces détachées
pourquoi le fabricant téléphone ont du
mal à vous donner les pièces détachées
c'est une bonne question on a toujours
eu des difficultés d'approvisionnement
nous en pièce détachées d'origine on
arrive à le faire de plus en plus avec
certaines marques mais de base c'est
vrai qu'on a toujours eu des difficultés
depuis 2013 à nous approvisionner en
pièce détachées d'origine constructeur
pourtant pour les smartphones
commercialisés depuis janvier 2022 les
constructeurs sont dans l'obligation de
mettre à disposition des réparateurs une
liste précise de pièces détachées
pendant 5 ans si certains constructeurs
ne jouent pas le jeu ce serait pour la
simple et bonne raison que réparer et
moins rentable que vendre du neuf mais
aussi parce que rendre disponible
certaines pièces dévoilerait les secrets
de fabrication
[Musique]